build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is B
build three separate check companies
have come together to create the world's
first fully capable flying bicycle using
what looks like a mountain bike frame
and two large turbine fans they're able
to create enough lift for five minutes
of flight with a test dummy on board the
idea stems from a famous Czech comic
strip character named Yan tes klatch who
is always trying to create a flying
bicycle inspired by Dutch engineer and
sculptor teo johnson jason almond built
this unique variation of astronomy's
sculpture out of Lego a strong beast
which means beach beasts in Dutch is a
large animal like sculpture made out of
lightweight materials they're propelled
by wind and have a distinctive style of
motion defined by their many spindly
legs
Jason's motorized Lego version is a
walking steampunk inspired fortress
complete with working windows and doors
handcrafted from high-density plywood
mahogany veneer solid brass trim and
glass Colin Johnson's the emperor's
cabinet is a wet bar built to look like
an 8080 Walker from Star Wars it's
currently on display in Vancouver at the
hot art wet city gallery for their Mela
forge be with you exhibition which
focuses on art based on Star Wars and
Star Trek Anthony how is a sculptor who
builds intricate wing powered metal
sculptures about faces his examination
of the human face and is built from
copper and stainless steel at almost
seven and a half feet tall about face is
made up of 100 individually balanced and
weighted copper panels some
free-swinging and others articulated by
spinning stainless cups as wind
interacts with the sculpture it creates
a hypnotic surreal effect of changing
expressions and distorted symmetry try
mo is a photo series by artist Sabine
Pearlman that reveals the inner workings
of various pieces of ammunition the
series was shot on a World War 2 era
bunker in Switzerland he believes that
the intricate beautiful nature of the
form inside the ammunition is so vastly
different from the destructive purposes
of the
object artists code logic created iron
mash a series of prints that makes Iron
Man with a variety of other fictional
characters including Darth Vader
Superman
Wolverine and predator and now for the
book paintings of ekaterina panic Innova
evolution is a project from Tyler Rhodes
that was made to teach people about
evolution and art the animation series
is a collaboration of five groups of
people and 460 drawings this one is from
the patrick henry school of science and
art and is made up of around a hundred
of their handmade creatures playing the
bad piper is the world's only
flame-throwing bagpipe artist here is
performing a CDC's thunderstruck in
Australia
unlocking the truth is a sixth-grade
heavy-metal band here they are playing
one of their songs in Times Square
finally sludge metal Giants Kailasa have
just released a video for their song
unspoken directed by Brody rush with art
by Tyson Schroeder
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo wo
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi an entire video
dedicated to your creations and as
always thanks for watching